Which video game adaptations were
originally slated for the silver screen?
What award-winning family drama
was almost a movie about octuplets?
Check out which TV shows were
originally planned to be movies.
The gun-slinging bounty hunter from a galaxy
far, far away had a tumultuous journey before
finally landing on the Disney streaming service.
Shortly after Disney acquired Lucasfilm and, by
extension, the "Star Wars" franchise, the company
announced spin-off films telling stories adjacent
to the original "Star Wars" saga. "Boba Fett" was
initially supposed to be one of those projects:
originally, Josh Trank, the director of
"Chronicle" and the catastrophic box-office
bomb that was 2015's "Fantastic Four," pitched
his version of a Boba Fett narrative to Lucasfilm.
The studio was enthusiastic about his ideas and
announced his admission to the "Star Wars" family,
with Trank set to direct the
Boba Fett standalone production.
After the failure and drama that spun out
of "Fantastic Four," Trank quit the project,
understanding that he'd probably be
fired if he didn't drop out himself.
Eventually, the project landed in the
hands of "Logan" director James Mangold,
but a certain famous fictional smuggler seemingly
ruined plans for Boba's big-screen future.
The prequel film "Solo: A Star Wars Story," which
chronicled Han Solo's younger days picking fights
with gangsters and the Empire, was considered
a financial disappointment upon its release.
Disney's focus shifted toward
their new streaming service,
where "The Mandalorian" became a flagship series
for the service's debut. Thanks to that show's
success, plans for Boba Fett's own series
quickly followed, and the rest is history.
George R. R. Martin's "A Song of Ice and Fire"
novels are now as well-known as Tolkien's Middle
Earth fantasy thanks to the additional popularity
that the HBO series "Game of Thrones" brought to
the books. For years, Martin had been courted
by scriptwriters who eagerly wanted to share
their version of Martin's fantasy world in
live-action cinema. Like a King's Landing not
fit for the Dragon Queen's world, he scorched
these ideas to ash and cinder. According to
Entertainment Weekly in 2011, Martin claimed
that his book series was simply unfilmable,
despite visions to the contrary attempting
to sell him on the idea. The author stated,
"Even Tolkien took three feature films, and three
Tolkien [novels] are as long as one of my books."
Martin also noted that, after giving a
feature-film idea some thought, he felt
that his works were simply too mature. After all,
sex and violence saturate the entire narrative.
"Be quick about it."
Eventually, David Benioff and D.B. Weiss
approached Martin and proposed adapting his
books into a series. Since the show would land on
HBO, the mature content was no longer a problem.
Furthermore, Benioff and Weiss could take
all the time they needed to build out the
story over several seasons, depending on
the show's popularity. After reaching an
accord with Martin on the direction of the
series, film ideas were finally put to rest.
The White Wolf, better known as Geralt of Rivia,
has long been a mainstay of the fantasy genre.
Andrzej Sapkowski created the fabled
Witcher and authored a collection of
stories surrounding his exploits before
writing a sprawling saga. The Witcher,
known for his combat prowess, keen senses, and
hunting acuity, is capable of slaying the most
dangerous of monsters in the wilds. Geralt is
also often embroiled in the warring politics,
evil machinations, and drama of the most
prominent characters to populate the land.
Netflix was always a prime destination for the
Witcher to receive a proper live-action outing.
Although the character had appeared in a few
well-received video games made by Polish game
developer CD Projekt RED, fans were chomping at
the bit to see Geralt realized in cinematic glory.
"The Witcher" was originally going
to receive a standalone Netflix
film, but creatives behind the scenes
convinced the producers that there was far
too much material to cover in just two hours.
Convinced that the property deserved more,
they got the green light to move
forward with a Netflix original series.
"Mr. Robot" was a massive hit for the USA
Network. Centered around a mentally unwell
cybersecurity expert named Elliot, the series
deals with hacktivism and political issues of
all kinds. It received high praise from
both critics and audiences along the way,
winning three Emmys, two Golden
Globes, and a Peabody Award.
"I respect that about you."
However, many likely don't realize that
"Mr. Robot" was originally intended to
be an independently produced feature
film. In an interview with Forbes,
series creator Sam Esmail discussed
his creative journey. Esmail stated,
"When I saw it as a movie, I knew
where I was going. I knew the ending."
The problem was that he simply had more material
than he knew what to do with. Esmail continued,
"When I got to page 90 and I
was still halfway through Act 1,
that's when I decided, 'OK.
This can be a television show.'"
The showrunner still tackled the
series like a movie production,
treating each episode as if it
were a short film. Ultimately,
Esmail still achieved what he set out to do
with the narrative he'd originally planned.
Sure, the fiery vigilante of Hell's Kitchen
already received a big-screen adaptation
in 2003 with Ben Affleck taking on the
role of the blind lawyer Matt Murdock.
However, the Netflix "Daredevil" series was
also originally envisioned and pitched as a
film by series creator Drew Goddard. Goddard
explained why the film approach ultimately
didn't pan out in an interview with IGN: Marvel
nixed the idea, believing that Goddard's approach
was far too dark and violent. Marvel
simply wouldn't do an R-rated film.
Furthermore, Daredevil is typically seen as a
local hero, interested primarily in cleaning the
streets of his own neighborhood. That wouldn't
gel with the large-scale epics of the MCU.
Instead, "Daredevil" landed on Netflix, with
Goddard free to produce his far more mature
take on the character. Goddard, who'd
previously stated that anything short
of his adult vision would be inadequate,
was certainly pleased with this outcome.
Believe it or not, "The Sopranos"
was originally destined for theaters.
Imagine seeing James Gandolfini's
Tony Soprano on the silver screen:
it would have been a sight to behold.
However, this hypothetical film wouldn't
have been the cultural landmark that "The
Sopranos" series was across its six seasons.
According to series co-creator David
Chase, the show was conceived as a film
and pitched as such from the get-go.
However, Chase's manager at the time,
Lloyd Braun, suggested that his idea
could actually be a television series.
Chase gave it some thought and began to wrap
his mind around the mobster's life as an
ongoing series. The scope of his pitch
changed, but only enough to cover Season 1,
ending with Tony confronting his mother over
trying to kill him. Chase understood this moment
as the end of their tormented relationship, and
the second season had to work with fresh ideas
beyond the scope of Chase's original plan. In
the end, of course, Chase produced one of the
best TV dramas in history, which won 21 Emmys and
five Golden Globes during its time on the air.
"I'm honored just to be considered."
The winding family drama "This Is Us" likes
to toy with viewers' emotions. The story
follows the Pearson clan and their three
children, who are depicted at various ages,
but primarily as adults. They experience many of
life's greatest joys and heartaches. After all,
the Pearsons and many other supporting characters
reflect many facets of American society.
While the series has proved to be one of the
most successful dramas in modern television,
it wasn't always meant to depict
the same family that we know today.
In an interview with Emmy Magazine, series
creator Dan Fogelman revealed some juicy
details regarding the origins of the show. Instead
of Randall, Kate, and Kevin as the "Big Three,"
Fogelman originally penned an 80-page film
featuring a Pearson family with octuplets.
Ultimately, Fogelman decided that he didn't want
to follow a traditional narrative trajectory
with a beginning, middle, and end. He wanted
to explore a lasting story that continuously
unfolded in the past, present, and future
of a single family. The character-driven
nature of the show has proved successful,
engaging audiences and critics alike. Let's
just be thankful that we didn't have to
follow the chaotic lives of octuplets.
"Dumb luck."
In 2020, "The Queen's Gambit" took the streaming
world by storm with a thrilling period piece
based on the 1983 novel by Walter Tevis. The
Netflix miniseries centers around Beth Harmon,
portrayed by Anya Taylor-Joy. As an orphaned
youth, she becomes obsessed with and shows
a talent for chess, eventually developing
a drug addiction to help her focus on her
game and cope with personal loss. The series
chronicles her rise to fame in the chess world.
"The Queen's Gambit" novel had long been examined
for a possible feature film adaptation. In fact,
the late actor Heath Ledger, himself something of
a chess connoisseur, was planning on making his
directorial debut with an adaptation of the
novel before he tragically passed away. The
project was halted upon Ledger's death, and was
eventually pitched to Netflix as a miniseries.
Fans of the original Archie Comics likely never
suspected that it would eventually be adapted for
the small screen in live-action. The television
series on the CW Network, titled "Riverdale,"
features the exploits of the famous Archie Comics
teenagers, including Archie Andrews, Betty Cooper,
Jughead Jones, and Veronica Lodge. Positioned
as a teen drama, "Riverdale" goes big on its
mystery themes and has enjoyed a lasting legacy
on the CW network with its deliciously dark tones.
Of course, Archie almost found himself
on the big screen. Warner Bros. sought
an adaptation of the character on film. The
creatives behind the TV series originally had
their idea dismissed and were asked to work on
Archie's first-ever live-action appearance in
a time-traveling story featuring Louis C.K.
of all people as the iconic high schooler.
The studio imagined a Riverdale filled with
portals that would open up to other dimensions.
That was just a little too wacky, a bit too
much like a live-action "Rick and Morty."
Thankfully, "Riverdale" show creator Robert
Aguirre-Sacasa didn't like that idea.
He walked away from the whole ordeal,
only to be contacted later by the studio to
commit his original vision to television.
Like the bounty-hunting Boba Fett,
Jedi Master extraordinaire Obi-Wan
Kenobi was once set to return to
the big screen in his own film.
After "Solo: A Star Wars Story" didn't exactly
gain the financial returns Lucasfilm and Disney
were looking for, their approach shifted focus.
The streaming service Disney Plus changed the
game for Lucasfilm, giving Ewan McGregor a chance
to reprise his role on the streaming platform.
"Hello, there."
In fact, both Ewan McGregor and Hayden
Christensen are set to reprise their prequel
film roles in the "Obi-Wan Kenobi" series. The
show offers fans the chance to finally see what
Obi-Wan has been up to for all those lonesome
years in the desert wilderness of Tatooine.
While his top goal is to protect
Luke Skywalker, it seems that much
more went on behind the scenes than
Luke could've ever possibly imagined.
As a live-action production, the popular video
game property "Halo" has been through development
hell and back. Aside from smaller productions like
"Forward Unto Dawn" and "Nightfall," a true-blue
Halo film with Master Chief positioned as the
lead has been in the works as far back as 2005.
Alex Garland, known for "Ex Machina" and
"Annihilation," was hired by Microsoft to
write an adaptation of the series for the silver
screen. Guillermo del Toro was attached to direct,
but ran for the exit when he decided to
head up "Hellboy II: The Golden Army."
The project eventually bounced over to "District
9" creator Neill Blomkamp, but a tug-of-war over
creative control between Fox, Universal, and
Microsoft resulted in the project being shelved.
"Halo" once again entered the live-action
spotlight with the announcement of a TV
series in 2013 with Steven Spielberg attached
as a producer. News emerged that the series was
being developed for Showtime. After going
through several producers and directors,
the show was shifted to Paramount Plus,
where it made its debut in March 2022.
Now, "Halo" has received the renewed
attention it deserves in the live-action
space — although that might be up
for debate among longtime fans.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.